welcome to philanthropy in action where
we uncover the wonderful stories of
people who give their time talent and
treasure to change the world these are
stories of philanthropy I'm thrilled to
have Mimi Gardner gates here with us
today Mimi thank you so much for coming
delighted to be here we also have our
brilliant and dedicated Yale students
participating in the conversation
students please introduce yourselves
Linda hi my name is Linda I am a junior
history major at Yale and I i was born
in Shanghai China hi I'm Michael
scholten i'm a senior religious studies
major from Chattanooga Tennessee hi I'm
Stephen banks I am a senior computer
science major from Detroit Michigan hi
I'm Leslie bowl I'm a junior political
science major studying International
Development and I'm from Arlington
Virginia hi my name is Robert rich Nicki
I'm a freshman computer science major
from New York City Thank You Mimi
Gardner Gates is a philanthropist and a
scholar of Asian art she has been
curator and donor at the yale university
art gallery and the seattle art museum
she is now involved in an exciting
project in the do and Hong Buddhist
caves in the Chinese Gobi Desert her
influence has been significant in the
art philanthropic sector and elsewhere
she also serves as a trustee of Yale
University maybe my first question is
how did you get involved first in
philanthropy did you go to a religious
school as a child no i didn't have
actually growing up the one fact was
that my father's company had a small
foundation than it was a family
foundation so i knew that they gave
scholarships but then after i got into
college and then i was working full-time
and going to school full time to get a
graduate degree at yale and actually I
was here for 25 years some people said
took you that long but it was actually a
church where I first gave my money with
somebody from the church and in New
Haven asked me if I would give I think
ten thousand dollars for a capital camp
and I agreed but he was a friend and
that started me thinking and then
afterwards when I moved to Seattle and
to direct the seattle art museum but
when i became a part of the gates family
the whole culture of philanthropy I mean
it just even though we all get give
separately but it becomes certainly
ingrained in you write that aspect has
been recurrent a recurrent theme in the
with our gas in which you asked Julian
Bond how did you start you ask Harry
Belafonte how you start and you guys
don't lubinsky how you start and they
said because someone asks me do you
think that was the catalytic moment
absolutely and you know thinking back on
it that's when I personally first b-day
became interested in giving and realized
that what what a gift to me it was is
there a difference you actually said
that but is there a difference in how
you feel when you were making decisions
by yourself or words your family
involved and now that you are part of
the gates family has that changed how
you think about what you do well I think
it's sort of a complicated question
growing up my family was really not very
philanthropic my father was very
cautious his father growing up during
the Depression and it was only this this
corporation foundation that gave really
small scholarships and we still do it as
my one connection with my cousins but
after moving the Seattle and also at
that time my parents created a
foundation and they gave each of us a
certain amount each year to give away in
our communities that made me start
really thinking about what I was going
to do and then with the gates family
even though my giving is separate
and so is my husbands and our finances
are separate so mine's kind of mild by
comparison or modest by comparison to
other members of the family I think you
know we talked about it a lot and talked
about you know what you're giving to
what you're assessing and tell and then
the foundation the Gates Foundation
started in our basement and Bill and
Melinda suddenly decided that they look
that they really wanted to give but they
were both working full-time at Microsoft
and so bills dad whose first wife had
passed away and then we were together he
offered to help and so one day we look
downstairs and the largest foundation of
the world was in our basement and there
were three people working for it what's
that anyway now there are a thousand
people working for it and they've built
two huge buildings in Seattle and it's a
major major concern but it's I think
it's so important in terms of fully
lived life to really think about
philanthropy and to really see I mean
what can you do for your community what
can you do for the world how do you make
a difference and philanthropy is a
really key part of that now before I go
to our students how did that change your
personal relationship that it did it
change at all because now you're your
husband became one of the one of the
three trustees or two at that time of
the entire or was he the only trustee of
the foundation at that time he actually
bill and melinda make the decisions and
my husband sits in on a lot of them and
warren buffett gave his money and warren
buffett is now trustee but bill Melinda
I think are really the ones who are
making and decide on the major major
buckets giving let's start with Linda hi
well we in our class are nearing the
phases of deciding which organizations
we're going to donate to and you have
plenty of experience in doing
that one of my top concerns is how to
manage risk so in the field of
philanthropy maybe even more so than the
field of business many individuals and
NGOs face failure and actually
accomplishing their goals how when you
give your money do you assess these
risks and take these risks into account
when you donate I think you have to be
willing to fail and I'm a great believer
no matter what you're doing that it's
important to be bold and take risks and
and to allow organizations that are
doing but you you're really in looking
at an organization and how you're going
to give your money away you have to
evaluate you know are they going to do a
good job are these people who know how
to manage the organization do they know
what they're doing and do you feel
comfortable making a commitment but I
still think you have to bet it's worth
it taking taking risks and actually when
when Warren Buffett spoke to Bill and
Melinda he one of us one favor said is
don't just go to safe places really
tackle tough issues and if you're going
to tackle tough issues you've got to
take risks so what's your passion I well
one of the organizations that we're
thinking about is called mycelium school
and it is an organization well it is
it's only just beginning and it like the
founder believes that in our current
model for education today we don't have
enough emphasis on action on actually
doing things putting our learned
knowledge into action so he wants to
incorporate that into the field of
social enterprise and create a school
based on that philosophy but it's never
been done before what we don't know the
person personally and it's just I think
it's very hard to assess the success
rate of an individual that we've never
met but I think if I were you know
single-handedly making the decision in
the class I would love to be able to
give mycelium school a chance can you
inter for your viewing on skype we
probably
again we would definitely try to do that
yeah well would see some of the
questions you would ask him oh I guess
you know what is his approach how does
it go you know what or to what is his
strategic see of a strategic plan save a
three-year strategic plan is he looking
long term how does he see it evolving
who are the other investors does he is
he investing in it mm-hmm how much
weight do you put on the idea versus the
the talents of the person who's supposed
to execute the idea I think I probably
weigh them equally that idea usually get
you involved but the talents really is
having strong management is really
critical you know having somebody who it
really knows how to think and act and
and to really move a project floor we
would you agree with this statement one
of the things that you said it seems
radical which is you have to be willing
to take risks you have to be willing to
fail and where I see it's not radical is
from people who come out of a culture of
innovation people come out of Technology
and so when we hear of people who have
created great wealth in the technology
sphere they say similar things to what
you just said that is so important that
if you're going to have an outlier
response you have to be able to take
rosie has to be able to fail or
scientists say that you have to it's not
a negative thing you just exclude that
its information you exclude that but
when you speak to other philanthropist
who have been around and are more
traditional or in an inherited wealth a
sort of context there's a different
level of timidity and it's as if you get
defunded if you fail because you should
have all succeeded but it would cut the
world's complex problems I don't
understand why your point of view isn't
winning out over the other point of view
because if you're not being innovative
and willing to fail and fund people who
are failing you're not going to change
the world I think it's really critical
that you be willing to I don't think of
myself as a
antha post you know I have lots of
patience and as an art museum director
and other things although you know the
family is that everybody is a
philanthropist um to some degree but in
the art museum world I tell people
you've got to take risks and you've got
to be bold and I think no matter what
you do in life really taking risks when
an opportunity presents it season it and
going with it is important and I think
it plant be you can't you you have to be
willing to let people fail Michael um
thank you so much for coming that's
great to have no sir so one of the
premises of this class is the idea that
the donor has taken a hundred thousand
dollars and allowed 25 different people
to sort of make this decision rather
than centralizing that decision with a
single person and I'm curious how you I
mean you're you're close to a foundation
which is in many ways we're the most
centralized giving sort of operations in
the world and I'm curious what do you
think what are the advantages of having
such a sort of us a centralized model
versus a more diffused giving a lot of
people the money to they give away type
of approach well somehow you have to you
have to reach a focus right and so I'm
sure I mean how have you all been able
to reach a focus and I think that's
something that won't work Francis you're
not a few days going on right now bad
that's what we're trying to figure out
it's very difficult I make decisions by
my myself which I like and not not by
commit the foundation they now are very
targeted they have global health they
have global development and in the u.s.
education and then Northwest giving is
the small piece and libraries their
small piece okay you probably read about
it so yes so there's different parts to
them but the ultimate new years in a
climate decision kind of comes down to
bill actually bill and melinda or do
they delegate do but they also they read
avidly okay young bill he reads
voraciously and he has a memory where he
never
dance oh good and yeah you know it could
be hiv/aids it could be osteo samaya sis
you know all these different things he
actually has really on vacation take 14
books well okay and they're not books
not fiction that I would you know and
and he really learns about and he also
hires people who are the best experts in
their field and its really worked and
they also had somebody in education they
weren't keen it was on dividing large
high schools into small high schools and
they really decided that was not the
best strategies so they turned it over
they actually hired somebody new and now
they have different strategies okay so
being been willing to adapt and maintain
I think maintaining flexibility is
really important but it's interesting as
to how 25 of you how you come to a
decision you're all happy with and you
know that encompasses so do you put it
in different buckets how are you
dividing it up well at the moment we
divided into three focus groups there's
a global health group poverty
alleviation group and a social justice
group so that gave us at least somewhere
to start on focusing which organizations
we might want to consider funding and
now we're trying to narrow it down to a
top list of ones that were really
passionate about and then from there the
debating starts so it's interesting also
what you want you're not including yeah
so you know for me the arts I really are
really vital and I'm going to just bring
it read you a quick quote which actually
comes from Michelle Obama which the arts
are not just a nice thing to have her to
do if there is free time or if one can
afford it rather painting and poetry
music and fashion design and dialogue
they all define who we are as a people
and provide an account of our history
for the next generation and I think the
Arts in terms of enabling us to explore
who we are and who other people are that
they really also free you up to to look
at the world in different ways in the
see different world and also cultural
organizations most many people assume
that ticket sales pay for the entire
organization which is not true and what
did those organizations mean the
community and that's something to think
of and it may not be affect you right
now but when you live in a community
think about what the arts and culture
mean you know can you imagine Paris
without the Louvre New York without the
Metropolitan or but these organizations
and it's the same thing for symphony
orchestras where almost all of them had
some meaningful impact on our lives and
to keep them going it's worth thinking
about some piece of philanthropic giving
anyway one of the exercises that they're
now going through you know they're only
two days away from their decision making
is that they came up with their own
priority areas which that Leslie just
enumerated God and they're designing
their own metrics but in response to
what you said one of the things that was
part of their exercise is we left and
Donna Dubinsky suggested this that you
leave money aside sort of discretionary
now because you can get rigid in your
formulation and that having that
discretionary money allows you to then
think outside the box of what you've
confined yourself that there are other
things that you think about
relationships their passions that aren't
justified in some metrics way but
deserve to be funded some of the most
meaningful giving that I've done has
just been something that hit me
personally one is a Chinese calligrapher
who lives in New Haven who's 99 years
old one of the best artists I mean one
of the best Chinese calligraphers alive
not just female calligraphers but one of
the best calligraphers alive and one
thing i did was i was able to preserve a
core of her work in the seattle art
museum
and that actually was through my own
giving which it came from a very deep
personal connection and to me that was
that was incredibly rewarding Steven so
the can you continue on this line we
found that it's reasonably simple to
compare two organizations that are in
the same sector so if we have two
organizations looking to fight malaria
in Africa we can look at which one is
more effective but we're having a much
harder time comparing organizations that
are very different given that the class
as a whole doesn't have a set of first
principles that we're trying to fulfill
you have any advice as to how we can
compare funding education in India with
fighting discrimination in New Haven
with stopping malaria in Africa how can
we compare those are right i guess it
was me I would probably divided that you
know say I want to do a third here a
third here yeah it or something in a
quarter quarter and a half or do
something I think it's hard to compare
organizations across who have completely
different missions unless how meaningful
are they and I you know I tend to give
from my patient so but with with a group
and giving I i would i would divide it
up by percentages I don't know that's
kind of it kind of crate but I think
it's really hard to compare well you
also have to weigh whether if you
divided up by equal percentages but you
have less interesting organizations who
can capture a larger proportion of the
money because it's a third but you have
incredibly good organizations but in one
category they're fighting over that same
third so part of the flexibility was to
allow nimbleness but I think that's good
but also the frustrations related to
that so you have passionate arguments
you disagree and
so I find myself passionate about trying
to maximize impact or goodness ah full
stop and it seems that the way to do
that is through global health that's the
most obvious way to effectively create
good outcomes saving lives preventing
suffering and so forth and this differs
from the passions of other members of
the class many who are interested in
helping the local community or in
providing education and I don't know if
I'm leading toward a question here but
the these are the troubles that we're
we're facing I guess many people have
not not just it's not that there's just
a set of people in the class we're
passionate about global health and asset
who are passionate about education even
within the people the group of people
who support global health they may be
passionate about they may be supporting
back category for different obviously
you don't want to do you don't want to
divide it up into too many right into
into too many grants but somehow being
able to convince the others to come to a
conclusion in terms of rankings well but
but to me would be you know what what's
the priority but it's hard I mean global
house and the gates foundation's every
human being every person has the right
to live a healthy productive life is the
the mission statement and having
traveled in Africa and India in
different places seeing the work it
really is incredibly meaningful and I
can easily understand but or do to do
international national and local I mean
that's a different way of doing it sure
well one of the things that Steven often
brings up is it is easier to measure one
success with mosquito nets or pills and
distribution that it is to measure some
of the more more for social change
systemic problems that people would like
to address and so justifying investing
in social change versus or in art versus
investing in
and something that you could actually
count how many mosquito nets you gave
out how many kids actually got saved
versus last year is an easier process
how do you convince one of the other
that's what you're looking for I you
know I think you have to look across
categories certainly you know I I just
kind of a request yesterday from the UN
for ten dollars per bed net or
recharging it huh they're overcharging
you oh there you go we've studied these
measure counted they've done incredible
so how much should have been that cost
four to five dollars yes there we go and
what organization is it doing it against
blurry foundation do you agree with that
Leslie the against malaria foundation
might be best at distributing bed nets
whether they're best at fighting malaria
I don't know would you suggest I think
the against malaria foundation does a
really good job but they're focusing on
a very different part of the fight
against malaria than the against malaria
foundation is and Mary no worries yes
like this even if you get the whole the
whole grand of a hundred thousand that
you're giving away all to this yeah it
how much effect well you would save a
quantifiable number of lives that
otherwise wouldn't be saved even if
you're not stopping the problem but I
think you still have to look at other
parts of human existence it can't just
just be that I don't know it's my own my
own passion is that social change and
there are other things that affect
people's live is lives as well nossor do
you agree with this I agree i mean my
personal preference would be to have
some sort of combination between
something where you can very easily say
we definitely saved this many lives with
this much money that's not where I would
put all of our funds because I agree
with you that there's a lot more to
human existence that's important but for
something with a donation as small as
ours I'm perfectly comfortable with
donating some part of it to something
more
quantifiable that we can say mm-hmm now
you get a chance to ask your question
okay my question is taking this in a
slightly different direction so as part
of the Yale corporation I'm sure you're
aware of the power of having just yells
name associated with something and we've
talked about this a fair amount in class
regarding some of the organizations that
want a smaller amount of money or that
maybe we can't fund it all and I was
wondering if you think there's any value
in say publicly supporting an
organization but only with the Yale name
if we can't give money to everyone I
think it depends what the organization
is and if it is it going to make a
positive difference and if it is then
you know I think I would think that
would be great do you think that'd be
more salient with local New Haven
organization rather than abroad probably
okay it's good to know yeah but I and I
think from the time when I lived in New
Haven I think it's really terrific what
Yale and the community and becoming
together is much more powerful than it
was when i was here at several decades
ago and but I think for there are a lot
of great really great organizations in
New Haven helping people in lower income
and educational organizations and you
know I think those are worthwhile are
you giving are you thinking of giving to
any anything local we are there are
several under consideration right now
yeah like that's I think it'd be great I
I just you know quite a bit some in
Seattle and I do something Gobi Desert
so how do you respond to build on
Leslie's question when the person who
wants the grant says to you the money
would be great but even if you give me
something nominal just to say that you
recognize me so that I have Mimi Gates's
brand as part of the award this
positions me in a better way to
negotiate
other donors and funds because you gave
me an investment do you do you weigh the
brand that you lend to a potential
grantee as well as the possible
investment yeah I've never I I think
it's just I like the idea of if if I
believe the organization's meaning in
the cause is meaningful then I like the
idea of you know having but to divide
things up into too many little pieces I
don't believe in doing that I believe
making choices even if they're difficult
choices I like it when it when a name
helps leverage and leverage other gifts
I'd like giving money and asking for a
match I think that and that recently
happened to me with the Gobi Desert and
it was for conservation which is a
really important causes how do you
preserve these caves and training
Chinese conservators to do wall painting
conservation and so I met with men and I
said you know I said if you give you
know x number i will match you and he'd
said fine I'll matter we have that
experience right here with someone in
your seat Jesse Fink and his wife Betsy
who were here who founded priceline.com
liked the idea of one of the
organization's under consideration
called a whole wave which deals with
organic food and farms and he was
talking about since both he and she had
gone to forestry school that this was
some that was appealing to him and it's
why said one of the metrics the class
looked at was candy or zation leverage
the gift thing said okay I'll match
whatever i'll match what you did go and
immediately and then we saw is that on
your list metrics definitely the how
much do you really muscle people to give
so for example in the gobi desert
it's an amazing and important
undertaking but say this class didn't
have art as one of its priority as a
culture as part of its part of the years
how do you how do you broaden that
conversation with with potential donors
who don't operate in that space and this
would be a new a new wave in a new
category I talk about what means to
humanity in terms of of history of cross
cultural connections and I think you
just whatever it is you talk as
passionately as you can about what the
cause is and that the caves in Dunhuang
because there's their singular they
preserve a whole history of the Silk
Road in in greater richness and greater
depth than any other site so I I try and
convey my passion but I don't expect
everybody else to share it yeah do you
get that you ever have to battle with
people who would like a quid pro quo who
say well I'll support you if you support
me I think I'm modest enough that it
doesn't affect me so so so drastically
uh-huh so but certainly and I'll tell
you when I wouldn't I made when I was
director of the seattle art museum I
made a patient in case for the Arts all
the time because i had to fund that
institution so i did and in terms of the
muscling was probably much heavier than
it is now yep dun wan caves which are my
primary focus Robert well I kind of
wanted to take the discussion a slightly
different direction and ask you how
about your work in different
philanthropic spaces because you've
worked a lot in the arts and that you
said that's what you're really
passionate about I was wondering how
your work in the arts which you said
it's important to be very risk-taking in
informs your work with sit with the
yellow organization with the with the
Yale organization with uh yeah what with
yet
yell arts and different and education on
campus so with the Yale with the Yale
art gallery I just having having been
director a long time ago etc I have
tried to fund their as well to balance
that which I don't consider so
risk-taking but what I have looked at is
Asian art I think whatever you are
involved in personally following your
personal passion is really important and
I gave some thought to to what degree
does your personal career influence that
and our does and yet Yale does and I'm
indebted to Yale I want to give back for
what they gave to me over the time I was
here and so asian art was my passion so
actually doing something for Asian art
to encourage the display and study of it
but particularly for teacher and student
exhibitions so that's what interested me
but I balance that with the north west
african american museum which is the
startup and one thing that fascinates me
and I could be of help to them because
they've been in the museum field and so
this museum started up from nothing and
it went through some painful growing
pains we're actually it was poorly run
when it was they built a building and if
the person who was in charge anyway it
you went over budget and got out of hand
a little bit so had to help pull it down
again and now and we I was instrumental
in getting a change in leadership and
it's doing beautifully though that that
also is I don't know if I have any
specific risk taking at Yale but
the the the arts at Yale are you know
something but is it is a real gift in
terms of the richness and the
distinguished the collections as well as
the study of the Arts here in the
professional schools the way that we
frame philanthropy is time talent and
treasure you have clearly merged your
talent which is your scholar vision art
you enjoyed this field with your
philanthropic with your treasure when
you think of this if we went to sort of
high up into the ear without the
specifics and you think about advising
folks who thi a potential grantee to
certain deliverables or to a certain
vision but don't I don't have that
expertise do you lean in a certain way
which is when when you have the talent
to actually use that talent with your
philanthropy when you don't have the
talent but think you have the talent I
try to recognize I don't know but I and
I think I look at several buckets one
what is art and that's probably more
prominent for me than a lot of people
but I think it really isn't important in
terms of who we are and then I have
another bucket that's education heritage
university is out in the yakima valley
in Washington ninety percent of the
children so come from families where no
one's ever been to college 50 / span
Hispanic twenty percent native american
and it's in a huge agricultural valley
and there are no other schools around
and a lot of the people who go there our
work have to work and even have families
and children so they really struggle so
I was just out there recently and that
to me is in the education department and
with my time I volunteer at head start
so three and four year olds are fun
you don't have to plan you don't to
worry it doesn't take a lot of brain
power but i found the teacher in a head
start who I really like and so you know
I do that environment I am more and more
concerned about environment the kind of
climatic chaos we're all experiencing I
think just underlies that in the
northwest environment is very prominent
so and that's something the Gates
Foundation doesn't do and but it's
something that has become increasingly
important to both actually my husband
and me so we're doing doing more in in
that department and i'm trying to think
so and humanitarian service so human
services I think being a woman
influences me in terms of really caring
about women who are living on the
streets and children and homelessness
and domestic violence in all of us and I
do that in arc in the community in
Seattle with the YWCA because they have
they do transitional housing they help
to get people up self-supporting they
have a women's shelter and that's what I
do in that department so I sort of do
these four buckets I don't necessarily
decide I'm going to spend so much money
or percentages on each one but I think
of it in those categories there's
something about your character that's
coming across that I find exciting and
and part of a type so there's a quote
that resonates with me but sounds very
much that it would be in keeping with
you and so my question is will this be
in keeping with you which is a quote
from Winston Churchill in which he said
success is going from failure to failure
but with enthusiasm do you do you find
that your enthusiasm cat it'll carries
some of the water in the Indies
philanthropic exercises and Part B of
that question is do you purse
we get something out of being engaged
with your time and talent and treasure
as as well as of course the impact
you're making by investing such time
talent and treasure Oh on the on the
last question I think there is
absolutely no question that I'm sure
have you all found that I mean are you
it'll be interesting to see once you
make the decisions right right now
you're probably preoccupied with how are
we going to make this happen I'm going
to do is because I really care about is
it going to win how much we going to
give to it and those things I as I've
gotten older I it's one of the great
pleasures of my life is being in a
position where I can give back and I
think that's you know it's such here in
you know going to Yale having you know
having a life that's been blessed in
many ways is being able to give back and
to do some some great things than some
of them unexpected and it to me I love
spending the time and and thinking about
giving and giving and spending the time
volunteering so it's it's almost a
profession now which I like all right on
the enthusiasm yep yeah it convinced
each other with your patient everything
don't I think not be 24 don't be afraid
to express it and be enthusiastic and I
think it's a true whatever you do in
love is is to really express yourself
and express your patient final question
it's fascinating when you read some of
the earlier philanthropist like the
gospel of wealth by Carnegie and folks
who wrote something that sounds so
different on what people say today with
some notable exceptions and what they
write is when they have accumulated
capital and they've been incredibly
successful as capitalist it's not their
money
they say we're conduits we have had
special skills and gifts that allowed us
to create great wealth and so what our
duty is to return it back to society yet
for a lot of people in this particular
moment which is also a sort of a new
Gilded Age people say it's my life I
should be able to do what I want with it
and what do you think of that of that
conversation because you are engaged in
a certain or at least some conversation
with great wealth yeah I I just think
that you know I think far too much in
arch in the United States today people
think about themselves and think about
things that I have to me they're mad and
yes you've earned the money but but
think about community and think about
other people and think beyond yourself
and how can you make a difference in the
world I mean how could how can you and
you know there's just there's so much
that needs doing and you have the means
to do it and you have the intelligence
to that when you get out when you
graduate and you go out you can use your
intelligence to make something great
happen and it doesn't have to be in
terms of money and how much you make you
can also be in the nonprofit world or
you can make money and give it away but
I think far too many people I think of
it as being selfish and instead of
giving it away I just I wanted to cite
one quote sure which is Katharine Graham
who said to love what you do and know
that matters what could be more fun and
she did it when she broke the glass
ceiling and about what really inspire
you know her being in the publishing
world when she never thought she could
do it and wasn't necessarily about
philanthropy but i think you know to
love what you do and know that it
matters what could be more fun and
philanthropy is is is really fun it's
hard work
and forget it in a big way you've got to
evaluate no sense and do all those
things but it's fun and think of it that
way thank you so much Mimi I hope it was
helpful it was incredibly helpful and
thank you so much students we have been
inspired with Mimi Gates's enthusiasm
and she the fun that she has in being
philanthropic and engaging in exciting
projects that are moved by by your
passion now what are you going to do to
change the world